tout le lot il a évolué un avons nous
tombions des costumes maintenant nous
trouvons que la robe de touloulou donc
les martiniquais verrons bien que il ya
comme il ya une évolution mais malgré
l'évolution les codes reste c'est-à-dire
total anonymat
c'est le plus important pour pour le
touloulou de guyane c'est que le
touloulou soit à nos nîmes et mystérieux
voilà ce que je compte faire passer
quelques messages
au cours de cette soirée alors l'année
dernière nous étions sûrs sur des
soirées
auprès des dancings et tous et nous nous
sommes rendu compte que beaucoup de
personnes qui venaient de l'extérieur
participer au bal paré-masqué dans les
dancings les universités comme on les
appelle mais qu il y avait un petit
manque la chaussette le bal des gants un
petit kaboul parce qu'il y avait la
perruque dont comité pas la cagoule et
tout et c'est pour ça qu'on s'est dit
que ce serait bien de venir en
martinique d'aller en guadeloupe d'aller
au métropole pour bien préciser que le
touloulou du bal paré-masqué en guyane
dans les dancings que l'on appelle les
diversités
il faut être totalement est recouvert de
la tête aux pieds ou c'est l'occasion de
changer d'image sauteur de toulouse oui
sur tournante inique tension est
toujours persuadé que soûlard oublier un
homme et c'est pas ça du tout parce que
en guyane il ya le touloulou que c'est
la femme qui dirige qui commande c'est
la reine de la soirée et nous avons le
taux lolo ce que je vois déjà les ses
lacets les hommes qui prennent le pas ce
sont les rois de la soirée ce sont eux
qui invite les femmes
en guyane le le bal paré-masqué ça fait
à peu près 300 300 disant ça existe et
de notre culture et de notre coutume
dans notre tradition
après l'épiphanie jusqu'au mercredi des
cendres tous les samedis maintenant à
partir du jeudi
mais tous les samedi nous avons le bal
paré-masqué ça fait partie de notre
patrimoine c'est notre patrimoine
d'ailleurs tous bangui années et tout
quand je dis bon guyanais c'est sûr les
gens qui habitent la guyane
qu'on soit d'origine d'ailleurs c'est
pas grave plutôt bon guyanais qui est
dans le carnaval c'est que à partir de
l'épiphanie jusqu'au mercredi des
cendres en est où loulou on est bal
paré-masqué et tout autour de ça il ya
toute une
composantes de la société qui fait avec
les collectivités qui met en place la
l'aménagement des abords et du bal
paré-masqué des dancings revenir la
manifestation que vous organisez alors
concrètement c'est à partir du miti et
qu'est ce qu'on verra alors pour cette
manifestation nous avons voulu qu'elle
soit comme en allant chez napoli là pour
les cités puisque ce sont nos deux
universités les plus importantes le
touloulou donc nous allons présenter
notre fameux
rétrospective du costume du bal
paré-masqué et après nous aurons un
repas enfin nous aurons des mets
typiquement guyane et je vais les nommés
parce que comme vous dites il ya des
martiniquais qu'icône est donc il y aura
l'appui notable de boeuf qui est de la
commune de sinnamary et puis nous avons
aussi les leurs y crever que nous avons
décidé de de faire c'est mais là pour
faire découvrir parce qu'on se rend
compte et nous étions très étonnée
commente inique camp depuis on ne
connaît pas ses produits
donc il ya ça et après il ya un petit
bal de 2h 2h30 à peu près en fait plus
tous les produits sont venus tout frais
de la grillade tout aux frais de la
guyane c'est un c'est un contrat qu'on a
eue avec le directeur du cs monsieur
gilles michel quint monsieur
extraordinaire qui a cru en notre projet
et puis pour présenter les costumes on à
la collaboration de l'association est là
où ce sont les amis de l'ouverture c'est
une association de danse qui qui qui qui
travaille comme nous aussi qui oeuvre
pour la tradition du pays
en guyane en dehors de la musique delà
de la biguine de la mazurka de la vase
en dose de la bonne musique mais avec le
rythme du carnaval guyanais
donc j'espère que notre manifestation
sera prendre conscience coeur le
carnaval de guyane est différent de
celui de la martinique
ça c'est normal et c'est très bien mais
le toulouse du bal paré-masqué de guyane
c'est un touloulou qui est élégant
mystérieux et anonymes et par la même
occasion les cavaliers qui sont dans le
bal paré-masqué des dentiers
ce sont des cavaliers élégant et de très
bons danseurs